à damas on vit sous la protection
d'allah et sous celle du parti baas
depuis presque un demi-siècle ici les
présidents de la république se succède
de père en fils le mot démocratie est
une idée bien lointaine et bien
abstraite ce qui se passe ce matin est
rare
l'opposition au régime osent manifester
pour dénoncer la détention de
prisonniers politiques
d'un coup sous le regard passif de la
police des hommes viennent casser la
manifestation
les opposants sont encerclées châtel de
la pl
agresser insulter
accusé de trahir la patrie
notre conscience de citoyen avec les
fortes chaleurs il puisse encore que
celle des parties basses ce sont des
miliciens envoyé par le pouvoir
c'est cette manière de faire qui prouve
que nous ne sommes pas en démocratie là
c'est pour ça qu'on nous empêche de
parler librement
nous étions ici pacifiquement et
tranquillement c'est ça la situation
aujourd'hui en syrie
nous sommes nous aussi prise à partie
notre cameraman et notre preneur de son
sont agressés violemment
impossible de continuer de films et
des membres de l'opposition nous invite
dans un endroit plus calme la crise
libanaise nous explique-t-il est un
sujet hautement sensible
point de vue qu'il n'y a aucune raison
pour que nous continuions arras et
olibeau
la sécurité de la série ne dépend pas de
notre présence là bas cet après midi le
président syrien bachar el assad a
annoncé le retrait total de ses troupes
du liban ce retrait devrait se dérouler
en deux phases
reste un calendrier à donner il devrait
être présenté au secrétaire général de
l'onu la semaine prochaine